[Music]
I'm Dennis borsch and this is games you
should know by heart actually this game
you will not know the whole game because
what we will try to grasp in this lesson
is the heritage of Petrosyan the Tigran
Petrosian heritage which is the
positional rook sacrifice
now this positional rook sacrifice first
popped up in the zurich candidates when
he played reshef ski
so the ayran Tigran as he was known was
under kind of some pressure
why played efore and what if black will
be forced to take on e4 which he soon
will be he will lose all that grasp on
these very important d5 and E 5 squares
so Tigran dear minion world champion
starts to pile some pressure on the e4
pawn rook e8 Queen at 4 B 5 ship D 1 o
g7 g 4 fini 8 e 5 a 5 rookie 3 and now
Petrosyan came up with a concept that
we'll see in many many recent games and
actually was revolutionary it's black to
move and build fairly unusual blockade
that was very not not very known at that
time yes yes rook rook the eight first
rookie won and now rookie six yes the
idea of rookie six the point is that
black wants to stop white from expanding
with the pawns if the pawns start
expanding it's over a four in black
continued with his plan how can black
continue with his blockading plan yeah
rook d5 well in general luck is not
crazy about blockading with the rooks he
located with the rook on e6 this time
because it was necessary but other
pieces in just love outposts yes so 97
was played by Petrosyan as the knight is
headed to d5 Bishop takes it was forced
F takes and now this is kind of a weird
situation Black has next an exchange
your position but those black pieces are
much more coordinated so the position is
actually not that bad for black Queen f1
trying to run away from 95 ideas id5
rook f3 Bishop d3
and why decides to give back the
exchange takes takes b4 takes takes a 5
okay okay one Queen c6
a bishop c1
seven a six and basically they reach
dynamically equal position and they
agreed to a draw even they could go for
the endgame because let's say Queen
takes a six takes rook takes Queen takes
b2 and even though white is up upon this
knight on d5 just compensate for that
pawn deficit so this was a very
impressive first off by Petrosyan even
the legendary me halt all was impressed
when he saw this while playing in the
candidates tournament himself but this
was a start of a series of games which
will be featuring this idea now this is
a game between Elko and Moore's evich we
know more about more savage though and
in this position he knew about the
Petrossian sacrifice and he uses it in
this position with full effect
how did black continue in this position
this is kind of an unusual idea because
this is right after the opening usually
sacrifices don't really happen that
early black how black can use a
positional sacrifice or positional
sacrificial idea in this position
yeah we'll take c3 obviously F takes c3
and now Queen e7 and mores a bitch's
play will be in full principal Petrosyan
like play like what so this will this
will definitely be in the style of
Petrosyan because he will try to occupy
important squares for the exchange and
that was the basic idea of Petrosyan
sacrifice before how can we try to
occupy the important dark squares yes
well we can only play one move well you
have to because okay not h5 it's a fine
move more savage decided to play Knight
d7 first Castle and now Knight h5
so it's true it transposed but it does
matter what you choose in the position
so black is basically trying to take
over all the black squares and it's in
general a closed position which doesn't
really favor rooks so how can we
evaluate this position then roughly well
you're saying that white is slightly
better I'm not sure what will be better
if the position opens up and if white
manages to open up the position but if
black will manage to close off all the
lines for the rooks black will be the
one pushing for one but let's see how
the game goes Queen d2 95 and I take c5
Bishop e5 and now we can see that this
Bishop on e5 is a real monster
it might help develop a decisive attack
with Queen h4 and Queen g3 it might even
how
some night jumps on the other side white
only has a rope that can just move two
squares but doesn't really do anything
so I'd even say we played just few moves
but more savage means position improved
dramatically 92 trying to cover up these
vital squares on g3 and f4 Bishop d7
rook f3 trying to make use of the two
rooks okay a fate gaffe one b6y the
black play b6 yes yet to solidify the
position and also against any potential
Queen sorties to Queen a v b3 Knight f6
King h1 King g7 Flex position is very
solid now could because these two
bishops are much much more active than
these two rooks and they have potential
in the long term very real black tried
to play in this position on which side
yeah
yeah so what is fairly defended on the
queenside
but not as much on the kingside could
because the black squared bishop is
sorrow is really missing from the
position
Queeny 3 h 5 min f2 night h7 hinting at
night g5 which can be annoying
Queeny 3 H 4 rook F 2 Knight f6 where is
that night heading right now because
this is a sudden turn of plans
yeah g3 yes through night h5 and g3 okay
three night h5 Queen f2 g5 and it's very
very nice play by more savage as he's
not in a rush to play Knight g3 what
would happen if black will play Knight G
3 here how can black counter this I mean
how can white counter this yeah
so black just plain ig3 check nine
things G three let's say h6 g3 how can
white kind of consolidate his position
any ideas
we can see that there's a lot of
pressure on the h3 pawn so tongue
sometimes we sacrifice for other reasons
yeah of course rook takes g3 and yeah
and now the situation stabilized for
white it's not as bad as it was before
so it's important to remember that if
you have material advantage always think
about the idea of giving it back for
some positive results for here but
actually equalizes after rook takes g3
ideas g5 rookie 3 f6 a nice little pawn
chain by Moore's evich as he gets ready
to assault on the kingside pinna 3 rook
e8 gain g1 Queen e8 very nice maneuver
trying to bring the Queen over to g6
beam f2 v g6 look at 3 g4 takes Bishop
g4 look at 5 Bishop takes e 2 and now
this Bishop takes c3 is a very strong
move because obviously white would be
more than overjoyed if more savage will
take on f5 because Queen f5 and white
has chances to survive here but after
Bishop takes e2 there's no chance that
this Bishop on e5 will ever be opposed
by any strong pieces between take C to
93 Queen f3 h3 so actually more savage
is not looking forward to take any of
these rooks he says these rooks are not
good enough for my pieces I'd rather
keep my lights with my light pieces on
the board and actually I just realized
how bad his position is and he actually
really reside resigned here because of
gtex h3 then we just take the rook with
check
in otherwise the pond will just promote
and like we'll just ignore those two
rooks and even if let's say white would
take on e5 first off we can play H to
check what we can just stoic ly take
back on e5 and we're still winning so
this was a very good display that
sometimes light pieces are much stronger
than the rooks in closed positions and
now I'm going to show more games that
will show how strong these light pieces
can be in these closed situations so
here's another position between hunger
Hunger is two very strong players at one
point they were number one and number
two I think in the Hungarian rankings
and black is under some pressure but our
MA she finds a very good defensive idea
here
it's black to move and equalize so we
can see this position kind of resembles
the key game that Reshevsky Petrosyan
game so it's always good to look back at
the grades because they come up with
great ideas and you can use them later
on in your own practice the first game
was played in Zurich in 1953 and this is
2003 as you can see so that's how
important it is to know the classics
so what is the strongest piece in whites
position
the Queen on g6 but actually it's not
the Queen that is really that
threatening which piece is the most
threatening in this position can someone
tell me which piece is the most
aggressive piece and whites position any
ideas which piece is the strongest what
the knight
yes exactly the knight so if you located
which piece is the strongest for white
what can we do about it
yes not h4 is there any tricks for white
no tricks because the knight if let's
say white would play hazardously and
take take my G 6 well unfortunately he
can take what the knight said doesn't
work so Queen g4 and now as you
correctly pointed out rook takes at
floor positional exchange sacrifice
happens Bishop f4 and now black is down
material so black needs to tread
carefully now but if he does he can
stabilize this situation let's take a
look how can we stabilize this position
for black obviously the pawns that are
on white squares are well defended by
our bishop so other ponds that are on
dark squares are in bigger danger of
being exposed so we need to cover them
first how can we make sure we never get
made it on g7
can I have five exactly he played rukka
faith first but after that he played 9f5
but rook f8 was just to kind of
destabilize this bishop on f4 here and
Knight f5 now it might seem unreasonable
that he plays Knight h4 clean g4 it
takes on f4 we can't faith clean a rook
age one and night F root page one and
Knight f5 so it might seem he's
unreasonable that he sacrifices his own
exchange and then he moves his piece
back to f5 well the night was so
dangerous it was worth a look and this
night will be very stable here the only
way one could get rid of it if white
sacrifices on f5 but that would be very
dangerous as the H bond is very weak so
it continued with Bishop e3 Bishop e8 f
for Bishop f7 ship f2 rook b8 finish
three King gauge seven okay - Bishop e8
and soon the players agreed to a draw
because the g7 pawn is comfortably
defended by the f5 night and the b5 is
protected by the bishop and what cannot
ever really double on the b-pawn let's
say here rugby - then I just take on a3
so you can't really move all of your
works to the B line and if a for then
there is always this idea of b4 and
there's always a big blockade by black
so in general black has a very nice
blockade of fortress as you will you and
he used this with
the petrosyan technique sacrificing the
rook for good peace basement all right
so let's see three so this game was
played between our ischenko and vidit
with it who recently reached 2700 c5
takes takes 97 castle knight c6 this is
the so-called armenian variation or the
putin variation because this was often
blamed by the putin with very good
results also stockist left sakis played
this line and made a lot of comments and
good suggestions in these type of
positions between g4 Bishop d7 h4 look
at v 9 g5 in general this is a defensive
system for black but if white gets too
aggressive he might run into trouble
look at fate hinting on rook takes f2
well why doesn't want none of that
8 6 H 5 green d8 well if H takes g6 of H
stings g5 then H things g6 and there's a
naughty little mating idea that is set
up by white what is that meaning idea
yes yeah yeah root K Jay King takes
Queen h5 and Queen 8 7 mate so h5 Queen
d8 so with it is making sure that most
of his pieces are taking part in the
defense otherwise he can easily get
checkmated in this line not h 3g 2 x h5
green g3 so white is willing to
sacrifice upon just to open up the
position so in general and in these
games and these type of French
structures white is trying to open up
the position as much as possible while
black tries to keep it closed
h4 Queen h2
ninety-seven night f4 and black comes up
with a great move here
yeah yeah rook takes off for I mean he
doesn't play rook a for yet but it's
going to come very soon 92 96 so I
thought he could take actually right now
on Knight f5 and it would still work but
with it thought otherwise
Queenie 892 and g6 at for Queen f7 look
f1b five seven and now black's rook is
trapped
but do we panic here not really because
we're willing to sacrifice that Brooke
still so what is the classical way of
defending that yes
97 yes so after king c1 bishop e8
eventually white takes on f5 and now we
get the position very similar to the
first one we saw between laco and all
mocchi but with the difference that the
king is on the Queen side and the pawn
was already taken on h5 so I would
evaluate this position as slightly
better for black as white we'll have to
face some attacking ideas later on we
should be one trying to activate the
bishop but the main issue in this
position still haunts white as this
Bishop hits its own pawns on the whole
position it cannot really find any
targets bishop g6 Queen d2
Queen f7 where is this Bishop on g6
headed to it's trying to find a very
nice safe spot where it could hit the c2
pawn constantly
eight seven yes of course okay shrieking
it [ __ ] push a page for Bishop eight
seven a very clever idea because after
this the Queen will be free to maneuver
around King a to rugby eight notice that
black is in no rush to move the Queen of
knife seven he rather puts his rook on
b8 signaling the idea of before but not
yet deciding where he is going to put
his Queen he might put his screen on a
seven or even h5 but he doesn't want to
decide yet rugby one Queen h5 that was
the whole point
for example if black plays Queen a7 why
could play rugby 1 and there is no Queen
h5 idea but after rugby it will be one
there is this Queen age five idea
pinning the rook on h3 and in mobilizing
all those white pieces Queen age to
Queenie eight back Queen D to be four
and now this was actually a huge temple
for black because the Queen from e8 will
hit this a four square C takes Queen a
four so black is getting ready to
sacrifice some material to open up the
position along the lines in front of the
White King b5 but white or ischenko
who's the 2700 there himself doesn't
want to open up the position at all
Knight takes h4 rook h4 Bishop takes C 2
will be 2 this should be 3 in takes b5
f5 and now with it finds a final
decisive combination which will wrap
this game up
obviously at the moment White's position
is ok-ish but if the position opens up a
little bit white we'll be in big trouble
how can black try to open up this
position this bishop see to check runs
into Quinn takes it well in order to
have a decisive advantage in this
position we need to let our queen into
the game queen 1/4 that's too slow
yes c3 yes it's a big pawn sacrifice
because if it fails it fails badly so
white is forced to take because it's
also a double attack Queen f1 check
between c1 and here's a brilliant move
played by black which will decide the
game
which brilliant move does black play in
this position now Bishop seats exactly
very nice move by bidat the rook can't
take it because it would be kind of
illegal the Queen can take it because
it's illegal the same way and what if I
take on c2 with the king
what happens if I take with the king
yeah just rook c8 when's the Queen and
ends the game so a very impressive play
by vidit sacrificing the rook for the
night and just building up an attack and
our ischenko was basically just trying
to defend but eventually black broke
through with this c3 idea and Bishop c2
check okay this is also the favorite
line of conrad Holt the young talented
American player and he played this
against Charbonneau as well c4 takes
Queen up 7 so he played Queen f7 instead
of Bishop d7 IG 557 Queen e2 v5g for
tonight takes in g6 Knight f4 Queenie
for f3 g5 and now the unsurprising rook
takes f4 happens Bishop f4 and how does
black continue here remember that black
is trying to build a blockade somehow
and then to maneuver around and then he
tries to maneuver around White's pieces
yeah g6 would lose to rook takes h6 this
time
well if g6 rook takes Queen g7 the White
Queen will move to h2 and black will
have a long struggle after a long castle
and rook h1 the problem is that as as
long as white has the age line black
runs into trouble so black doesn't have
the luxury to give away the age line
exactly Bishop ea8 will be played first
he played rook f8 but then Bishop e8 and
now Age 5
yes rugby 197 g6g fix move is a very
nice move by white it's better to
sacrifice that pawn because otherwise
he'll have just a dead bishop on e3
staring at all his own pawns which would
render it rather useless g6 Queen takes
g6 guess white is kind of afraid of
Queen g3 ideas so he plays King f2
Knight a5
rook g1 Queen 8 7 next position is much
much preferable because he has all the
chances to maneuver around meanwhile
white will have to guard both the Queen
side pawns on C 3 and C 2 and the pawn
on f3 Bishop g5 h4 what's the idea of h4
yeah to allow the bishop to go to h5 and
hits on f3 f4 b4 after him I decided to
cut out his own Bishop black decides
it's due time for some action so he
plays before kind of undermining this d4
pawn and after the pawns fell White's
position automatically collapses takes
takes Queen d2 d3 takes takes and even
though what managed to get away with
these palm palm breaks this b-pawn got
really strong Queen B - we should be 5
Queen 2x B 393 what would happen if
white will play Queen takes b5 yes
yeah Queen c2 checked yeah Queen c2
checking f3 Queen takes age to just like
as it happened in the game
rook G to Queen age 3 King F 294 check
92 and now there are too many decisive
threats by Black Knight f3 check is
coming h3 is coming so why it was forced
to take but that's losing takes takes
Queen takes d4 and now blacks the one of
the exchange correct and black won the
game so last but not least I want to
show a game between molar and talked
about raha me on will start from this
position obviously this comes from the
same Armenian variation which thoughts
of is known to play for a long while and
she will show her skills in this
position g4 white obviously is trying to
open up the position and try to mate but
he is confident and takes on h5 Queen
takes h5 row cafe putting pressure on
the f3 pawn f4 Bishop ee8 hinting on
this nice little trick of rook takes f4
queen h2 and how should black continue
in this position
obviously thoughts have built up a
battery along and hitting on the f-4
pond but she needs a little bit more
firepower to actually crash through 96
exactly putting more pressure on the f4
pawn rook h1 and now she plays very very
aggressive and good move Knight takes f4
would be a little bit dubious because of
Queen takes h7 mate so she didn't play
that yes eight six two simple h6 so
onerous for us to play King III well if
he would take here she can just take
back tix and rook sacrifice takes rook
takes f4 and because Queen age 7 is only
a check their King let's say King he -
she can just take on c3 and blacks
attack is decisive
so Molnar decided to play King III
instead but now she crashes through with
very energetic play how did she continue
yeah Knight takes f4 indeed not f4 is
ill-advised because Queen takes c3 so
Bishop takes f4 was played rook takes f4
and Molnar decided to move his game to
d2 but what happens if he'd have taken
on f4 Queen C 3 in c3 King f2 yeah
King f3
Queeny 5-wood munch on a pond but we can
continue with very nice energetic moves
and that would make our position very
good yes yeah g5 and even though g5 is
very aggressive it's very good in this
position as the rook will enter it rook
takes f4 and whit will be decisive
so who care for King d2 but even though
he's trying to stabilize his position
she doesn't back down and just finds the
biggest blow in this position she finds
the decisive blow in this position how
can we just shatter all all of this pawn
Center built by molar
yeah
rook f2 what does white play and what he
what does he play well Queen h4 wouldn't
make much sense
if if g3 then Rukh f3 happens there's
not much difference between penis ring
g3 so cringy one was played and now root
takes you to correct and now her queen
enters with decisive threats and you can
see how disorganized all the white
pieces are we need three Horner tries to
just get some synchronicity between the
pieces but it's quite difficult Queen
takes c2 king he one Bishop g6 bringing
more pieces to the attack rook f1 takes
takes Bishop d3 check King g1 it should
be for Queen f2 do we really want to
exchange in this position or not with
like no definitely not so where should
we bring our Queen Queen d3 that's a
possibility but if we can we should try
to win tempies if possible
yeah queen c3 that's what she played
rookie one queen aged three and more
nervous aynd as if he would play Queen
aged two she'd take on g4 king f2 let's
say check c3 and either the pawn will
just promote or she'll just made white
so mana resigned and thought of showed
how you can play this position that
energetic play and how you can defend
your position as well as Bank on the
counter play in these types of positions
yes I mean it is still exchanged up for
white but he's at yeah he's kind of in
deficit right now because she has way
too many pawns and an aggressive Bishop
on e4 so that's basically Petrosyan
heritage and remember that in closed
positions light pieces can often
outweigh the rooks and you can use them
to full effect
like in this game and the game between
our ischenko and with it thank you so
much
you
[Music]